[Musica]
ogni azione a una conseguenza tutto
quello che facciamo quotidianamente
lascia delle tracce sul nostro pianeta e
queste tracce possono essere più o meno
grandi questi impatti possono essere più
o meno evidenti alcune cose le
percepiamo subito le comprendiamo subito
altre volte ci sono degli impatti che
invece sono un po più nascosti e un po
più difficile vederli però se non ne
abbiamo consapevolezza e se non capiamo
dove si insinua non riusciamo neanche a
capire cosa possiamo fare per ridurre
quello che l'impronta che lasciamo sul
nostro pianeta
quello che serve però in alcuni casi e
ampliare il nostro punto di vista
cercare di guardare oltre e cercare di
allargare un po il sistema di
riferimento che abbiamo per vedere tutto
quello che c'è dietro ogni singola cosa
che facciamo per parlare di questo
parliamo di questo che è uno degli
strumenti che tutti sicuramente qui
abbiamo e che utilizziamo
quotidianamente
a volte ci accorgiamo che uno strumento
che ha un impatto sull'ambiente di sotto
ce ne accorgiamo quando la tac chiamo la
presa della corrente però non c'è solo
quello dobbiamo allargare un po il
nostro punto di vista è la domanda che
ci poniamo e qual è l'impatto che è uno
smartphone ha sull'ambiente
e questo impatto lo andiamo a misurare e
valutare in termini di contributo al
cambiamento climatico
per misurarlo usiamo comunità di misura
l'anidride carbonica che andiamo ad
emettere
e ci chiediamo appunto quanta ne del the
carboni che emette l'uso che facciamo
del nostro smartphone e poi anche il
nostro smartphone spesso
partiamo da un esempio molto semplice
potrebbe essere anche un messaggio che
inviate una telefonata che fate ma
partiamo da questo esempio che l'invio
di una mail una cosa che facciamo
abbastanza frequentemente anche perché
lo facciamo per lavoro non solo per
diletto e la domanda che ci poniamo è
appunto quanta anidride carbonica e
mette una singola mail
per fare questo però come si diceva
dobbiamo ampliare il nostro campo di
d'azione il nostro ragionamento perché
per mandare una mail non è necessario e
non è sufficiente avere soltanto uno
smartphone quindi un terminale dal quale
digitiamo la mail e poi premiamo invio
per mandarla abbiamo bisogno anche di
una connessione a internet
abbiamo bisogno di tutto il sistema che
ci consente di trasmettere i dati
e poi abbiamo anche bisogno di un centro
dove questi dati vengono archiviati un
grande data center e tutti questi
elementi devono essere in comunicazione
tra di loro e nel momento in cui tutti
questi elementi ci sono e ci consentono
di mandare la mail e stanno funzionando
consumano energia elettrica e oltre a
consumare energia elettrica dobbiamo
considerare che sono strutture fisiche
che sono state costruite
quando pensiamo al cloud ci immaginiamo
una nuvola pensiamo a qualcosa di etereo
di materiale in realtà sono strutture
che esistono e queste strutture sono
state realizzate lo consumato materie
prime sono
posizionate consumano del suolo oltre a
consumare energia e probabilmente quando
poi arriveranno il fine vita dovranno
anche essere smaltite era introdotto in
un qualche modo nel nostro sistema
chiaramente alla meno possiamo imputare
tutto questo impatto nei imputiamo un
pezzettino questo sistema è grande e
viene utilizzato per la trasmissione di
tanti tanti dati in proporzione a quelli
che occupa la nostra meglio attribuiamo
un piccolo pezzettino
anche detto questo se noi andiamo a
misurare quanto impatta una mail vediamo
che in realtà l'impatto è molto piccolo
chi si è avventurato in questa stima ci
dice che una mail leggera leggera
intendo un po di testo nient'altro
pesa circa in termini di impatto
ambientale zero a tre grammi di anidride
carbonica
se abbiamo una mail un po più pesante
perché ad esempio ci abbiamo attaccato
qualche allegato qualche file qualche
immagine
ecco che l'impatto potrebbe arrivare
anche a 50 gradi de mitri da carbonica
emessa in atmosfera ora diciamoci la
verità anche 50 grammi non sono tanto
sono ben poca cosa
però se noi ragioniamo in termini
globali e immaginiamo che io che ho un
account di posta elettronica oggi invia
una mail una mail leggera ma è piccolina
una mail che ha un grammo
di anidride carbonica e poi pensiamo a
questa mail che l'ho mandato io oggi ma
come faccio io la mandano tutti gli
altri possessori di un account di posta
elettronica
pensiamo che al mondo ci sono oltre 4
miliardi di account attivi di posta
elettronica
quindi se tutti quanti mandiamo una mail
in un giorno una sola ecco che il nostro
impatto assume un significato
completamente diverso abbiamo 4.100
tonnellate di gas serra emessi una mail
un giorno
proviamo a
volevo fare il ragionamento inverso e
immaginiamo che in questo giorno io non
mando una mail e come faccio io lo fanno
tutti gli altri quindi in questo caso
non andiamo ad aumentare nostro impatto
ma andiamo a ridurlo perché avremmo
evitato di emettere in atmosfera
queste 4.100 tonnellate di gas serra
e chiaro che non possiamo fare a meno di
utilizzare la nostra casella di posta
elettronica abbiamo la necessità di
mandare e mail perché lo facciamo per
mille motivi
però possiamo evitare quantomeno di
mandare delle mail inutili gli faccio
degli esempi
siamo iscritti ad una newsletter che
però poi non leggiamo mai
sicuramente tutti noi ci schieriamo le
newsletter anche quando abbiamo fare le
tessere supermercato e poi magari ci
arrivano ma non ci interessano le
leggiamo quelle sono mai del tutto
inutili e possiamo fare a meno di
riceverle semplicemente quando kiedis
iscriviamo alla newsletter
anche perché ricordatevi che anche
ricevere una mail a un impatto
ambientale possiamo essere degli
emettitori ancorché inconsapevoli
se dobbiamo inviare una mail con
allegato pesante possiamo anche
immaginare se questo legato l'ho
scaricato dal web di mettere un
indirizzo link nella mano
possiamo anche chiederci quando invia
una mail
quante persone ho messo in copia serve
metterne 10 o magari le bastano 5 o ne
basta una soltanto tutto questo è
ridurre mac potrebbero essere anche
inutili e poi non dimentichiamoci di un
ultimo aspetto
e cioè del fatto che una mail non
inquina solamente nel momento in cui
viene digitata ed inviata in cui in
anche nel momento nel pre solo fatto di
essere presente in un centro dati questo
perché per che occupa dello spazio e
sicuramente con la mail avrà un certo
numero di copie perchè comunque gestore
di posta elettronica fa un sacco di copi
dei nostri dati non può permettersi di
perderli
e anche noi stessi avremmo sicuramente
una copia di backup del nostro pc o del
nostro smartphone e anche chi ha
ricevuto la mail tutto questo
moltiplica il peso di questa mail e lo
spazio che occupa e questo significa
richiedere energia al server che cela
memorizzata per essere raffreddato per
fare backup e poi comunque occupando
spazio richiede la costruzione la
realizzazione di nuove infrastrutture di
nuovi data center
facciamo un altro esempio un'altra
azione che compiamo abbastanza
frequentemente anzi sempre più
frequentemente da quando c'è stata la
pandemia ed è
l'acquisto online
in questo caso però non ci soffermiamo a
ipotizzare a calcolare quanta emissione
è associata ad una questione rai ma
facciamo un confronto tra abitudini di
acquisto differenti quindi l'acquisto in
formato digitale attraverso il nostro il
nostro smartphone oppure la cuesta e
acquisto quello che facciamo nei negozi
anche in questo caso ci chiediamo quale
dei due ha un impatto maggiore ma poi in
realtà la domanda vera non è tanto
quanto dei due l'impatto maggiore ma
qual è l'impatto di ognuno di questi
perché c'è e quindi cosa possiamo anche
fare per ridurlo
ti faccio vedere i risultati di uno
studio che ha stimato
confrontato questi due
sistemi e anche in questo caso prima
però di far vedere i risultati
andiamo ad allargare il nostro campo
visivo per comprendere tutto quello che
c'è dietro l'una o l'altra soluzione
ovviamente quando acquistiamo qualunque
prodotto dobbiamo immaginare che
qualcuno l'ha fabbricato che la
impacchettato che la mezzo su un mezzo
di trasporto
questo mezzo di trasporto
raggiunge un
luogo dove viene smistato vengono
raccolti tutti i beni e poi c'è quello
che si chiama l'ultimo miglio ed è il
percorso che fa quello che il pacco che
abbiamo acquistato il nostro prodotto da
questo centro fino a casa nostra
se abbiamo acquistato
il prodotto online oppure se siamo
andati noi negozio è il progetto che noi
facciamo per raggiungere il negozio dove
andiamo ad acquistare e come vi abbiamo
detto prima
dobbiamo considerare tutta la parte di
consumo energetico che c'è ma anche
tutto quello che è la parte di
infrastruttura cioè tutto quello che è
stato realizzato e che consuma energia
per il fatto di esserlo
questo è il risultato del confronto di
cui parlavo prima
di primo acchito quando lo vediamo ci
diciamo beh tutto sommato andare cioè
fare un acquisto online a un patto più
basso rispetto che andare in negozio
però vi dico che non è sempre non è
necessariamente vero questo perché in
quella barretta azzurro chiaro che
vedete quando ci riferiamo al al
commercio tradizionale che quella che
impatta di più ed è il trash il tragitto
che io faccio per andare in uno più
negozi prima di acquistare il bene lì ci
sono tante considerazioni dietro
la prima è quante volte io visito i
negozi prima di fare un acquisto
se devo acquistare un prodotto né visito
uno o due o tre per poi poter comparare
quello che voglio acquistare magari
trovare l'offerta più conveniente il
prodotto che fa più al caso mio
quanto lontano è o sono i negozi
con che mezzo di trasporto mi muovo
quando mi muovo lo faccio perché
acquisto un prodotto perché ne acquisto
tanti vado da solo vado con altre
persone tutte queste domande ce le
possiamo opporre possiamo chiederci se
possiamo fare qualcosa per ridurre
quella barra azzurro chiaro che avete
alle mie spalle e quindi magari alla
fine avere un impatto sull'ambiente che
è inferiore a quello dell'acquisto
attraverso l'e commerce
ma anche quando acquistiamo online non è
necessariamente detto che abbiamo un
impatto basso che abbiamo emesso poche
quantità di gas serra in atmosfera
il patto principale con ragioniamo in
termini commercio elettronico è dato
dalla dal packaging c'è da tutto quello
che serve per avvolgere e per tenere
protette le merci che abbiamo acquistato
e li possiamo dirci va beh non è tanto
che dipende da me può dipendere da me
nel momento in cui io scelgo
eventualmente il fornitore anche sulla
base di questi tipi di considerazioni
però quello che sicuramente può
dipendere da me è invece il discorso del
trasporto l'ultimo miglio che viene
effettuato gli faccio vedere un'altra
categoria di consumatore sempre un
consumatore che acquista online quindi
visita online tutti i siti poi fai clic
e poi arriva la roba a casa ma un
consumatore diverso questo consumatore
che molto frenetico e molto impaziente
fa tanti piccoli acquisti di uniti nel
tempo non lo so
oggi compra un libro fa una settimana le
compro un altro fanno settimana un altro
ancora e soprattutto voglio che mi
arrivino a casa subito oggi li compro
domani mattina di voglio per conflitto
il libro che avevo prima e voglio quello
successivo da iniziare a leggere questo
tipo di consumatore ha un impatto
sicuramente superiore al precedente per
il semplice motivo che non dà il tempo a
chi deve organizzare la spedizione di
organizzare un sistema di trasporto che
sia efficiente in tutte le sue
componenti e in più spezzetta tanti
piccoli acquisti anziché e raggrupparli
in uno soltanto
vi faccio vedere un'altra categoria di
consumatore e non è così infrequente
quelli che fa quelli che fanno i consumi
e scolate gli acquisti misti un lancio è
una parte dell'acquisto lo fanno online
a parte in un negozio in questo caso
questo tipo di consumatore
nello specifico
acquista scusate si acquista online però
prima di acquistare ha fatto il giro di
uno due tre negozi per provare un capo
di abbigliamento vado nel negozio in
negozio dispone il nero z vedo quale mi
piace di più vedo le proposte che ci
sono poi ho scelto torno a casa e
acquisto online perché magari un lay mi
costa un pochino meno ho fatto bene alle
mie tasche sicuramente non ho certo
fatto bene al pianeta perché in questo
caso l'impatto si somma quello
tradizionale più l'altro quello
elettronico
questi sono un po di consigli li abbiamo
un po già detti mentre parlavamo che
sono i consigli per ridurre il nostro
impatto in ogni caso qualunque tipo di
acquisto facciamo elettronico o nel
negozio vero e proprio se non abbiamo
urgenza
aspettiamo che ci arrivi il pacco non
pretendiamo di averlo già domani
una cosa su cui fare assolutamente
attenzione anche tutto il discorso dei
resi considerate che quella cosa che voi
avete scelto magari in fretta senza
capire bene sarà quello che veramente
volevate vi arrivate dovete restituirla
a un viaggio in più da fare quello del
ritorno
se possiamo cerchiamo di concentrare gli
acquisti dallo stesso fornitore per
ridurre il numero dei viaggi che quel
pacco deve fare o quei beni devono fare
e poi in generale facciamo delle scelte
consapevoli anche sul fornitore
possiamo scegliere chi ci da quel bene a
rassicurandoci sul fatto che sia più
sostenibile perché per esempio ci viene
ha garantito che il packaging con cui mi
arriva a un livello maggiore di
sostenibilità e un minore impatto
ambientale e adesso veniamo all'ultimo
esempio e parliamo dello strumento in
quanto tale del nostro smartphone per il
solo fatto che esiste anche in questo
caso andiamo a chiederci quante missione
a il mio smartphone proprio lo strumento
che abbiamo in mano
anche in questo caso dobbiamo ampliare
il confine del nostro ragionamento uno
smartphone per essere
nella mia tasca deve essere di aver
previsto una fase di estrazione delle
materie prime e della loro fabbricazione
attraversare i componenti che poi
vengono assemblati viene prodotto il
telefono così come lo trovo in negozio
il telefono deve essere imballato deve
essere trasportato e poi alla fine
quando finisce il suo la sua vita utile
deve essere anche in qualche modo smart
smaltito poi magari possiamo essere
virtuosi rientra nel ciclo possiamo
essere meno virtuosi finisce in
discarica
senza dimenticare che consuma anche
dell'energia e dobbiamo considerare
anche la fase d'uso questo che vedete è
il ciclo di vita di uno smartphone e
tutte queste parti devono essere
considerate quando andiamo a cap a
chiederci quante emissioni ci sono nel
mio apparecchio
questo è un risultato di uno studio che
ci dice che noi adesso fino adesso
abbiamo ragionato in termini di come
facciamo a ridurre l'impatto
del modo in cui usiamo il telefono
l'impatto del modo in cui usiamo il
telefono impatto deluso pesa a malapena
il 14 per cento
l'altro 86 per cento sta nel apparecchio
la 81 per cento dipende dalla pa la fase
di fabbricazione della sua produzione
tra le stazioni delle materie prime fino
al cancello della fabbrica 4 per cento
sono i trasporti e il restante un per
cento dipende invece dalla fase finale
quella di
gestione del fine vita
questi calcoli sono stati fatti
considerando uno smartphone che ha una
vita media di 12,6 scusate di 21,6 mesi
e non è un valore a caso perché questa è
la vita media di uno smartphone
calcolata nel 2020 ed è se ci pensate
bene inferiore a due anni questo vuol
dire che prima dei due anni ho già
cambiato il mio strumento e magari è
ancora perfettamente funzionante avrebbe
potuto continuare a dare la sua attività
ma magari è uscito un modello più nuovo
più performante fa le foto più belle
abbiamo cambiato il nostro il nostro
telefono
allora cosa possiamo fare per ridurre
questo 86 per cento
sicuramente una delle prime cose che ci
viene in mente potrebbe essere quella di
scegliere il fornitore che ci assicura
che quello smartphone che lui mi vende è
stato prodotto in modo più sostenibile
ha usato magari delle fonti rinnovabili
a efficientato il processo produttivo
però questo noi possiamo scegliere il
fornitore in qualche modo muoviamo il
mercato ma c'è qualcosa che possiamo
fare anche noi nel nostro piccolo e
possiamo semplicemente allungare la vita
utile di quel telefono vi faccio vedere
il confronto tra
lo stesso apparecchio che ha una vita
utile media di 21 mesi di 33 li abbiamo
allungato un anno in più o di 42 mesi
questo il valore dell'impronta carbonica
quindi delle emissioni di gas serra che
a
questo apparecchio nelle tre ipotesi è
chiaro che più non vi amo la vita media
meno incide il rispetto all'anno quello
che la fase di produzione soprattutto
consideriamo che dopo 42 mesi potremmo
avere un apparecchio che abbiamo
utilizzato o potremmo averne dovuti
produrre due trasportati 2 e poi
smaltiti 2 e c'è una bella differenza
ora tutti i ragionamenti che abbiamo
fatto
li abbiamo fatti basati sullo smartphone
ma possono essere applicati veramente a
qualunque cosa qualunque cosa facciamo
chiediamoci cosa c'è dietro
perché è vero che tutto quello che
facciamo ha un impatto e
possiamo essere consapevoli e trovare il
modo di ridurre questo impatto ma c'è ci
sarà comunque però se è vero che ogni
che è inevitabile avere degli impatti è
anche vero che ognuno può scegliere
quale peso dare un impronta che lascia
sul pianeta
grazie
[Applauso]